be guest right now the head of the
world's largest hedge fund joins us in
an exclusive interview Ray Dalio is the
founder president and chief investment
officer for otter associates Bridgewater
currently has one hundred and fifty
billion dollars in assets under
management array were thrilled ahead
good morning oh you have been on our
show several times now and we have we
have started dialogue around what you
call the economic machine it's your
theory of how you see the marketplace
the world the economy has been praised
by people like Volker and Bill Gates and
other people like that and part of my
understanding of the theory is that
there are short term cycles and long
term cycles the long term cycle I would
argue is probably bad given the amount
of debt that we're just building but
when you think about the short term
cycles and where we are now when you
start thinking about the US and Asia and
Europe how do you see your economic
machine applied to those markets well
the first thing I'm going to get to
answer your question in a minute but in
a second but I do want to convey that I
think that we go so quickly to try to
think what's the economy going to do
next year without agreeing on how the
machine works and the economy works like
a machine and the only reason I'm doing
this interview and only reason I did
that video how the economic machine
works is so that to draw attention to
how does it work because if we can agree
on how it works then so many other
things come from that so that's we'll
talk about what I think is happening now
and so on but within the context of that
the economic machine is nothing more
than a transactions very simple thing if
I buy something from you I can buy it
for money
or I can buy for credit and when I buy
it for credit over a period of time a
credit is a promise to deliver money
right and so we begin a cycle and in
that cycle there are two cycles around
income at the end of the day you can
only spend what you earn but that's not
true over the short-run because you can
borrow money and so around that income
growth is our debt cycles and there's a
short-term debt cycle which we call the
business cycle we're used to recessions
expansions and then tightening and
monetary policy and recessions again and
with that also produces market cycles
around that
so I'd like to put where we are in the
context of that ok sorry for that
background but at least we can then look
at the world that way so now where the
u.s. is because it could print money
print money means the purchase of
financial assets financial assets went
up a lot and as a result of the them
going up a lot future expected returns
went down a lot so the return of
equities has gone down to probably about
4% and which is by the way in line with
cash being about 1% bonds being about 3%
return of equities about 4% so that
liquidity has has happened we are now in
the middle of the short-term debt cycle
in other words you're out of the
recession and you're not into yet the
tightening those middle periods are kind
of the boring years you know they're the
years like 2004 and 6 you forget that
they even existed what happened in 2004
and 6 you'll never remember 2007 8 you
remember so we're in that kind of period
in the United States what Europe now
markets went up incredibly between 2003
4 5 & 6 right no 2000 deputy mark no no
2004 at 5 & 6 were boring markets didn't
do anything for they flat out they start
with a language like that things a
little flat they started moving into the
financial probably had it returns the
returns in each of those years of single
digit returns hardly doing anything
boring we had 15 years of nothing
oh no but I'm also referring those
particular years in other words you take
2000 2000 was a period we have the
recession we have a thing then you pump
it with liquidity then you get the ball
market the big bull market in equities
and then in that middle period when that
things are not too tight or too loose
then you have that period so that's
where the United States is I would
suggest we can only go down from here
maybe not all black and then down I
don't know you know you're you're in
that middle that means that the central
bank's got leeway not too tight let me
yeah that's where we are and that's also
means probably pretty boring for
equities also you look at the return
there was a big gap between cash returns
and bond returns and equity expect two
returns if you look at yields what would
the expected yield be and that
normalized I'm just talking about the
u.s. now let's go to Europe
because the by the way all these
countries are in very different parts of
their cycle which is the interesting
thing
so now Europe southern Europe because it
could not print money could not have the
same reactions that we could could not
have that response and as a result what
happened is they were in a debt bubble
meaning their debts were rising faster
than income if there's one thing to pay
attention to is debt rising faster than
income is debt rising faster than income
if debt is rising faster than income it
can't do it forever and it won't do it
and if it's doing it fast
for a long time you're gonna have a
bubble the United States debt is not
rising faster than income now in
equilibrium and I'm talking not
government debt I'm talking about the
total debt if you take all the sectors
of the economy in Europe what it was
rising much faster than income and
unsustainable so you couldn't fund it if
you look at who buys the bonds they
wouldn't buy the bonds there's not
enough money to so they need a funding
gap they needed to have an adjustment to
bring debt right down to income white
right now what happens is in terms of
there's a result they only have to roll
over the debt they don't have to sell a
lot more than they sold before and so
that's an easier thing to do and so but
that's a depressed economy right because
you can't finance it on debt so they are
in a chronic depressions essentially
depressions that will remain there and
then there's a fiscal policy and
monetary policy the ECB will have to
ease another monetary policy but a very
different position in the cycle now take
China totally different position so
China is in the part of the cycle where
they need to type the debt is rising
very fast relative to income
particularly certain sectors of that
debt and so what you're having is a
tightening of monetary policy and you
need to have a tightening of monetary
policy
now all the markets and all the
economies are connected so what does
that mean
ok it means that we're in brief we have
a world in which we have an enormous
amount of liquidity liquidity means that
people want to buy financial assets so
we build up the prices of financial
assets and there they're not too high
they're not too low there seem to be
appropriate
we also have a lot of longer-term debt
you were referring to that that
longer-term debt means it eats money in
other words it requires money to pay for
it we have a lot of liabilities there
unfunded liabilities beyond the debt
that eats money and we also have a world
in which there's excess capacity a lot
of the capacity was built in China a lot
of capacity was built in the wall around
the world that produces a deflationary
pressures so we're in a world with a lot
of liquidity and also a lot of also
deflationary pressures existing at the
same time I want everybody if they can
though to do what
watch this half hour video how the
economic machine works I'm here at Davos
with policymakers and we are discussing
the most important right the central
banks and so on and it is all around
that it's 30 minutes and if they can
people can understand that I think it
would help them a lot okay great Ali oh
thank you that video is on YouTube we
should tell everybody see